hello everyone the London chest plastic
began today and none of the game said
yet finished so I decided to show you
one interesting game while I'm waiting
for some of the games to finish you know
to choose which one to show you as so
far they're all pretty equal positions
but it's a chess game you know but you
never know what can happen now this game
how did I find this game dotted Lada
tweeted about it on his Twitter page and
I'm also using his photos of Yulia here
Yulia Schwager is a woman's grandmaster
from Israel she also has the title of
international master this tournament is
being held in Poland in rock club or is
it Roth's love I don't really know and
it's a tournament consisting of ten
women ten women grandmasters and it's
quite a strong event in this game Yulia
shower is playing against a Katarina
italic and Katarina is also a very
strong international master she also has
a title of a woman Grandmaster
she's raided somewhere around twenty
four fifty although at one point she
came really close to breaking the twenty
five hundred barrier plus her husband is
a SWOT italic a Turkish Grand Master
that's why she's a Russian Turkish Grand
Master she's originally from Russia but
she married a Turkish Grand Master so I
get I guess she's Turkish now and you
know it always helps to have a Grand
Master husband you know free coaching
and stuff so definitely a strong player
Katerina and it's quite a match up
I believe this game was played in round
two so let's see this interesting game
we have E for c6 the caro-kann defence
d4 d5 and E capture Sun d5
the exchange variation C capture Sun
diva and now C for the pun of attack and
I think this is the first time I'm
showing a game with the panel attack one
fun fact and my brother-in-law almost
defeated
a grandmaster using the panel attack he
I mean he crushed him and he had a
completely winning position and then he
blundered
but you know that happens Knight to f6
Knight to c3
we have Knight to c6 Bishop to g5 and
Bishop to e6 guarding the defy
phone if Bishop captures on f6 occurs
push up to e2 Queen to a5 now developing
the Queen also pinning this knight on c3
now nice the e4 is the plan
c5 we have Knight to e4 now now the
threat is Knight captures on c3 but is
it Knight to f3 now Julia allows Knight
captures on c3 and is this is this move
good I Katarina played the Bishop to g4
here but why didn't she capture the
knight on c3 and it's I don't want to
say it's a mistake but let's just see
what happens because this is a pretty
this is move 9 so if you're a player of
the caro-kann you might find yourself in
this position
what happens if Knight captures on c3 is
B captures on c3 and after Queen
captures on c3 check you get Bishop to
d2 now with the tempo on the Queen the
only square available for the Queen is a
3 and after Queen to a3 Rock the b1 now
white is threatening to capture the b7
pawn and if you want to stop this
somehow for example probably you have to
allow it but if you want to stop it you
get Bishop to b5 now pinning the night
the threat is Bishop captures night and
then winning the road can be ache but
there is also another threat which
you'll see after Bishop to d7 defending
now Queen to c2 and the idea behind
Quinta c2 is the guard the d3 Square and
you'll see why after black plays
something his queen can't move anywhere
after something like a 6 and Bishop to
a4 e 6 now you get Bishop to c1 and the
Queen is trapped you don't lose the
Queen but you have to give up a piece
after Knight captures now you're
attacking Weiss Queen so we have to
first capture the bishop would you check
King captures and after Knight captures
and Queen captures on c5 you don't want
to exchange Queens since the black king
is on d7 and after something like Queen
to be to black now has three pawns for a
piece and white is better here I mean
three points for a piece that's
considered to be
compensation in itself but there's this
king and these seven rook is still
undeveloped on h8 and the position is
better for white but if you enjoy
something like this for black you're
welcome to go for it
so after Knight to f3 she doesn't
capture on c3 she plays the Bishop to g4
and now we have Bishop today - knife
capture Sunday - Knight captures Bishop
captures I need to clean cap
sorry Knight captures I need to protect
him out the d4 pawn and Queen back to d8
and maybe Queen to c7 was somewhat a
better move you know no reason to get
the Queen all the way to the starting
square and what do we have here it's a
pretty equal position okay white knights
are pretty clumsy placed here but both
of them have some nice ideas for the
future for example night at 493 at this
night can jump to f3 he can come to b3
or this night can come to be 1 and then
c3 you know a lot of options for white
here it's it's a good position we have
castles here by yuliya and the g6 by
ekaterina preparing to develop the dark
square Bishop on this strong diagonal
and to pressure the d4 pawn Knight to f3
now adding more protection to the d4
pawn Bishop to g7 before now and white
is definitely gonna go for some play on
the Queen side which moves like a 4 B 5
rook to be one before that probably so
we have a six stopping the immediate b5
rock the b1 castles by katarina queen d3
a for immediately was also possible here
but 23 is just as good developing your
Queen connecting rooks it's a nice
square for the Queen why not a queen d7
black does the same rook F to d1 and
rook F to D 8 we have Knight to c3 now
now this night will also be helping with
the pushing towards the b v square h6
not allowing any Knight g5 ideas h3 we
have g5 now and this g5
it's an interesting decision but it's a
it's definitely a good one for one
you're stopping Knight h4 with some
maybe future ideas of knife
actress ng6 but more importantly sorry
more importantly you're controlling the
f4 square white will at some point push
b5 first a ford MV v and then you'll
have to do something about the c6 Knight
blacks plan is to push east 6 then play
this Knight to e7 then go to g6 and then
jump to f4 so let's see it we have a 4
by white ecigs now this is kind of
preventing b5 from really threatening
that night b5 a captures a captures to
the night is now attacked on 97 we have
rook to a1 and now Knight to g6
preparing either a 5 or 9 f for
depending on what white plays rook to a
4 now Julia is threatening to double up
on the a file this is never Pleasant so
rook captures on a4 Knight captures on
a4 and we have Queen to c7 what ideas of
infiltrating would via Queen to a5 maybe
adding additional protection to f4 and
also adding adding more power to d5 push
after this pawn is pushed b6 now kicking
the Queen way we have Queen to c6
attacking the knight on a4 and Knight to
c3 and now you can clearly see that this
night here is planning to go to B 5 and
from b5 either to c7 or to d6 depends on
what my place
black stops this by playing 'if I've now
now nights to be 5 would be met with E
for winning the peace Queen to b5 EULA
here offers the exchange of Queens and
ekatarina declines this with Queen to b6
and this is a good decision if you
capture the Queen here captures captures
you don't have for example efore but
after 91 this night is still coming to
c6 c7 or d6 and this night will come to
C 2 e 3 and then will control f5 and
attack d5 so definitely a better
decision not to trade the Queen's
Queenie 6d captors on e5 Knight captures
on e5
and nights to the four would attempt on
the Queen Queen g6 this very nice
diagonal for the queen night - D - E -
and Queen to c2 now infiltrating White's
position pretty much paralyzing every
white piece the Knights can't move
because they're protecting themselves
the c3 Knight is protecting the rook on
d1 so white has to do something about
this rook the c1 kicking the Queen away
Queen f5 and now Knight back to d4 with
the tempo on the Queen and Queen to d3
now Ekaterina is offering an exchange of
Queens but this cannot be accepted if
Queen captures Knight captures this
comes with an attack on the rook also
you're losing the c5 pawn after the rook
moves so after Queen D three night stay
e2 was played rook the c8 attacking the
c5 pawn and Queen to f4 and now you
Lea's threatening Queen b7 to win the b7
pawn king h7 getting the King out of the
back rank not to allow any any
unpleasant checks Queen a7 attacking the
b7 pawn and here white white is already
clearly better
Yulia is better in this position and
black definitely should have gone for
something like Knight to d7 and after
you capture rook captures rook captures
and Knight captures attacking the Queen
also now you have a double attack
on this night and unfortunately for
black white is still better because this
b6 passed pony is a monster but this
this would have been better after Queen
e7 and night the sea fort was played
okay this is still coming with a double
attack on the knight on d4 but Queen
capture some b7 now with the tempo in
the rook rook captures on c5 and this is
the critical moment of the game white is
completely winning here with a move like
Queen to a7 this b-pawn is winning the
game it's getting promoted but instead
of Queen a7 Yulia played Queen captures
on f7 and it seems like you know it's
just this is just as good you know also
you want to pawn your
pinning this bishops old bishop
character son d4 is impossible it seems
even better than Queen to a7 but there
is one problem black has the only move
that actually keeps him in the game it's
nice to d6 and this comes with an attack
on the Queen and also now the rook is
attacking the rook on c1 so you don't
have to do something about this and
White has only one move to actually stay
in the game it's it's not a better
position for white anymore and Yulia
finds it it's Queen captures on g7 given
up the Queen King captures and rook
captures on c5 and of course Queen to be
one check King h2 and now black gets rid
of the path the strong past be pawn and
this game is infinity now it's very
interesting because White was completely
winning now the position is pretty much
equal okay
white does only have a knight and the
rook for the Queen
but you know the black King isn't very
safe the White King is perfectly safe
there on H do you know he has a lot of
points to defend him pretty much a drone
a drone game but it's very interesting
what happens rook captures on d5 we have
in 93 for f4 now as the f2 point was
attacked G captures Knight captures and
queen to b8 but pinning this night as
well can't really do anything active
Knight to d6 with check King f6 and now
rook to h5 threatening roar captures h6
Queen to h8 defending Knight d4 Knight
to d6 Knight to f3 Knight to f7 rugby 5
Queen to c8 Knight d4 Queen to d7 now
attacking the rook and the night so rook
to b6 check first King goes 3 592 and
it's very hard to do anything against
these two knights as they can always
protect themselves
Queen c8 we have Knight to g6 check now
julia will improve the position of both
nights King three four and now Knight to
f4 now again both Knights are protecting
each other but only now
they're a bit further up the board we
have kinked d4 Rock to f6 attacking the
knight Queen c7 defending h4 and here we
have another critical position in the
game there is nothing really either
either Yuliya or a Katarina can do in
this position you know probably a draw
is in order I don't know if any of them
ever offered a draw but you know
probably both of them it's pretty early
in the tournament it's round 2 you know
when I texted take some chances and what
a move like 90 g5 here it's actually
it's actually a draw you know no one can
do anything here if you capture it H
captures black is winning this night and
then it's really a draw but after h4
Ekaterina played King to e4 and here
black is now completely lost and the
Yulia finds it immediately if she plays
rock to e6 with Czech and now it doesn't
matter what black plays Black has only
two options you can either go King to d4
or King the king to f5 King to f5 was
played in the game but if King to d4
then rook to e7 you lose you lose the
night after Queen to C for defending
night to e6 check after King moves
Knight to a4 check after King moves
again you simply grab the night and now
you're easily winning this game with
white so after rook to e6 check
Ekaterina played King to f5 but now it's
really over Yulia plays King to h3 and
ekatarina italic resigns the game in
this position what did you resign what's
the idea well there is this terrible
threat of g4 checkmate and unfortunately
there's nothing you can do to stop it
if you play something like h5 and H five
seemingly stops the idea of g4 checkmate
but it really doesn't White has a move
that wins 9:37 check so what do you do
here King captures on f4 or you can
capture the knight and lose the Queen
King captures on f4 Knights to d5 for
King the king and the Queen it's game
over the
we'll come to five but now nice capture
screen and the knight is defending the
rook so all is well for white another
idea after King to h3 maybe Knight to g5
check but again it doesn't work as
simply you capture it and after it
captures g4 is checkmate again and maybe
the most resilient the defense after
King to h3 it would be something like
Queen to c3 check checking the king and
then not allowing him to push g4 but now
black has a problem white plays g3 and
now the g3 pawn is protecting the f4
night and now this Knight can come to e7
and deliver checkmate so only move black
really has is Queen to a3 you still have
to pin this pawn and okay we do have to
guard e7 but this only prolongs the
inevitable 97 check you have to give up
your Queen Queen captures rook captures
and with a rook and B being up a rookie
and the pawn your winning this game like
a boss so yeah that's the game after
Queen to h3 FF 3 in italic resigned to
the game and I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Tony more guitar
jerod Linum James w'iskey Chris Quinn
Kurt and Antonio most insky for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot a Jared Liam here is the one of the
first contributors to my channel so I'm
glad after a couple of months of
watching my channel you're still
enjoying the content
thank you very much Jared so as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon
hopefully with an interesting game from
the London chess classic season